like many cocaine users John sees it as
a party drug socially acceptable but he
would never admit publicly to taking it
how often do you use cocaine it's
usually just a weekend thing you know
when I'm out with the lads and a pub or
club or festival of something like that
it's more just a recreational thing I
don't do it every day or anything but
when you go out in the last you have a
few pints you know you have a bit of
coke to bring you back it wakes you back
up that's it really
yeah two years ago the charity add
action launched an online chat service
for drug addicts they noticed that this
discreet anonymous helpline was
attracting a high proportion of cocaine
users how prevalent is cocaine as a
topic it's on the idea of what's become
the largest ever survey of its kind in
Scotland or anywhere in the UK to assess
drug habits Sky News can exclusively
reveal the results the survey of 8500
drug users found 70% took cocaine or
crack cocaine some previous studies had
the figure at 30% the only drug used
more in Scotland is cannabis at 80% also
noticed that only 14% of cocaine users
seek help those on heroin valium or
prescription drugs are more likely to
address the problem and 90% of drug
users are working people or in education
what is it about cocaine that it is both
seen as a party drug but it also has
this stigma around it and it seems to be
widely used yet nobody's talking about
it it's it's an open secret we talk
about alcohol
wheeling oil in the business and then
smoothing away my experience from is the
cocaine is that truck now people think
always it's it's a middle-class
middle-aged dinner party drug but our
experience is from what we see online
it's everywhere so there's a whole group
of people out there who are class a drug
users and we don't know who they are
they are off the radar and this report
also suggests that a large number of
them are showing indicators of high
dependency or a dick
that might be their missing work or they
have financial problems or health
problems connected to the drugs and what
this report also suggests is that they
are not seeking help they're storing up
problems for the future this comes in
the weaker candidate for Prime Minister
Michael Gove has come under fire for
previous cocaine use and frontrunner
Boris Johnson refused to deny using it
author and columnist Brian E Gordon was
part of a similar media social circle
when she became addicted to cocaine
it destroys lives it tends to sort of
lead to people searching for the next
high if you see what I mean and and
obviously all sorts of Resident normal
reservations come down and it's you put
yourself in it makes you risky it makes
you inherently risky and you don't care
about the consequences until the next
day but cocaine is becoming an everyman
drug affordable and accessible this
so-called party drug is hiding in plain
sight society aware but blind to the
potential damage Jason Farrell Sky News